let's go to it's either Ally or Ali from
Finland welcome to the program
Ali Ali uh so so uh who do you want to
win in 2024 and who do you think will
win in 2024 you're talking about the
presidential race yes it depends who
runs I don't know who's I don't know
who's who the candidates are going to be
at
lordy who do you want to be the
president well I there's people I think
would be good presidents that I don't
even know if they're thinking of running
uh I think Jamie Raskin would be a great
president and I've mentioned to that to
him when I had him on the show uh I
think Pete boot Edge would be a great
president
um John ossoff probably lacks The
Experience so far but uh John ossoff is
interesting Stacy Abrams is brilliant
and you know I think would be a very
interesting president
um but you know a lot of this stuff is
Pie in the Sky it's like would George
Clooney make a good mayor of La I mean
maybe but I don't know that he has any
interest in running I I it's hard
because I I'm maybe too pragmatic or
let's let's see who runs you know get
honestly I think Gavin Newsom would be a
good president he's not the most
Progressive but he's striking the right
tone when it comes to dealing with
Republicans I think there's lots of
interesting people I just don't know if
any of them are going to run
right okay so the second question uh
what do you think are the greatest
priority goals for the country and how
would you prioritize achieving those
well I mean that we need I need 10 hours
really but zooming out I think the most
important issues for the country to deal
with that will trickle down and affect
other issues include campaign campaign
finance and how politics is financed
how elections are run where I would like
to get off of the electoral college
system and I would like to get off of
first past the post and we've talked
about do you do that via uh the national
popular vote in your state compact I
mean each of these topics is hours of
discussion I think dealing with climate
change because if you're in a climate
crisis you can't be an activist for any
issue
um and then probably number four getting
Health Care to everyone because if
you're sick and can't get care you're
also Limited in your ability to be an
activist to work to earn a living Etc so
I would say those are the four top
issues
right so so do you think like it's
better to campaign for the president or
Congress or
overall or or what was the best way
you're saying as a candidate or as a
voter
as a voter yes oh I think you can do all
of the above I mean listen you can phone
bank for multiple candidates you can
donate to multiple candidates I think
that it's it's not about more or less
important it's your your Congress person
and your senator
deal with different things than your
mayor and City councilor and the
president so I I mean in an Ideal World
people would be involved in all of them
and not all of those elections are at
the same time either
right okay that was all my questions all
right uh Ali from Finland how is Finland
these days
uh snowy snowy so okay do you live in
where do you live Helsinki
uh
what's that like is it a large city town
uh it's the third largest I think
baseball population what's the
population
uh you're putting me on the spot I think
300 000. oh okay very interesting and is
it a place where what what when does the
sun set at this time of year
oh it's like four o'clock oh all right
well that's not that crazy we'll stop by
like 10 and goes down like four so six
hours maybe oh the sun doesn't come up
until 10. yeah oh is that is that rough
yeah oh interesting interesting wow wow
yeah I don't know that I would deal well
with that well listen I really
appreciate the call it's been been great
hearing from you
sure you too all right there we go uh
folks we heard from all over the world
we went to Ireland we went to Finland we
went where else did we go we went
everywhere
um that's it for calls today I will take
calls again and hope to speak to you
soon we'll take a quick break and be
right back